we live
okay
good evening any everyone and thank you
for coming to tonight's hybrid New York
our Meetup uh once again I am not Jared
Lander my name's Noah Moross I'm a
computational ecologist and organization
called Eco Health Alliance and I'm pitch
hitting pinch hitting for Jared tonight
uh because he as of this week is at home
with a brand new baby so we'll all
congratulate Jared for that and I hope
you can make do with me this evening
tonight we have a hybrid Meetup we are
both online live streaming on YouTube
and uh we are also here at brain station
at SoHo in New York so before I get into
more announcement I'm going to hand this
presentation over to Julie who can tell
us a little bit about brainstation
all right good evening everyone welcome
um welcome to all of you virtually and
in person we're so excited so excited to
be hosting you all today
um welcome to brainstation I'm going to
give you a little introduction about us
and give you a very special announcement
um so bright station we are the digital
Learning Company we host boot camps and
courses for people wanting to get into
the learn digital skills we've hosted
over 100 000 professionals have been
empowered through brainstation and our
campus is globally and we're excited to
have you all join us today
um so our boot camps are really to
empower individuals and in their digital
success so we host boot camps for
students in data science software
engineering as well as ux design
one thing about brain station is we have
a large Talent network with over 700 or
7 000 companies we work with and here
are just a few that you might be
familiar with so we work with these in a
variety of different ways but we are
excited to have them as partners with us
orientation does offer a variety of
different scholarship programs so if
you're interested in taking courses or
boot camps with us here are just a few
of our scholarship programs that we
offer but tonight in particular I wanted
to offer we have a specific brain
station and New York open statistical
programming scholarship where you'll be
providing a full free boot camp to three
students at no cost those boot camps
will be starting in January and they
will run for 12 weeks it will be a full
immersive program so you will be eight
hours a day fully engulfed in data
science software engineering or ux
design if you would like to apply we do
have a link to that website if you would
like to join our team and be a part of
the scholarship for those boot camps the
start dates are January 24th they are
for all three of them again data science
software engineering and ux design if
you are interested again you can send
the link to or we will send the link out
to Virtual and in person you can sign up
with me if you'd like to at the desk but
we are so so excited to have this
partnership together and we're looking
forward to continuing in the future so
thank you and welcome to brainstation
okay thank you very much Julian thank
you very much brainstation for hosting
us tonight and uh for these uh New York
uh open sysical Meetup scholarships I
hope some of you out there who are
watching sign up for that uh so I'm just
going to jump into some announcements
before I introduced our speaker uh so
first of all jobs we uh always like to
use this Meetup so people can exchange
opportunities if they're looking for
work or they are looking for workers so
if you're out there watching and you are
looking to hire someone who might be
part of the New York statistical our
Meetup please go to our slack channel to
the jobs Channel and let us know about
it and we'll be putting that right in
the Stream in the YouTube comments
you'll be able to click and go over to
our Meetup slack Channel
uh uh just so you know uh one of the
links that you'll get there is links for
Lander analytics which is uh uh Jared
and this our uh meetups organization
they're looking for an account executive
a data science engineer and a shiny
developer so I'm sure there's someone
out there and this Meetup will uh be uh
interested in in that I actually am also
going to be hiring a data science in the
near future and that'll be something
that will be posted to the slack and the
next uh days or weeks if you are hiring
please make your way over and post your
jobs as well
um and uh hopefully we'll have some
like-minded people meeting up
next we have some events coming up
starting tomorrow is the neo4j developer
conference which is happening November
16th and 17th it's virtual it's online
we'll post the links for that so you can
register if you're interested in neo4j
and then happening December 1st and 2nd
is Lander analytics uh government and
public sector R conference if you work
in with or are just interested in data
science in government and the public
sector this is a great conference for
you it also will be hybrid it'll be
available virtually online as well as at
Georgetown University in Washington DC
there'll be speakers including David
Shore from Blue Rose research Kim Kai of
the Federal Reserve Bank Tyler Morgan
wall of the institute for defense
analysis many people from the FDA from
the US Army the Bureau of Labor
Statistics and and many more there's
also going to be a workshop on natural
language processing for Public Policy
research taught by William E J Doan and
and that'll be the day before the
conference but once again available in
person or in Virtual use the promo code
NY hack R for 20 for any member of the
Meetup here and you can visit
ourstats.ai for tickets
uh speaking of tickets we're giving away
two free tickets for attendees of this
Meetup tonight so all you need to do is
in the slack Channel or in the YouTube
comments say I want a ticket and you'll
be entered into the drawing and at the
end of the Meetup tonight we'll announce
who got those
let's see importantly for the New York
our Meetup pizza tonight we're in person
so we have pizza in this case from Lido
Pizza uh I'm not Jared so I don't know
where Lido Pizza is and I don't know
what kind of pizza it is other than it
seems to be some kind of thin crust
Sicilian thing
um he can give you more details you can
ask him after his paternity leave
uh if you have any questions tonight uh
please post them in the YouTube channel
post them in our slack chat uh I and
Nicole will be monitoring monitoring
those so if you're online and you have
questions of our speaker we'll make sure
to direct direct them to him during the
Q a session and speaking of our speaker
tonight we have Mike Kane Mike Kane is a
assistant professor of biostatistics at
Yale University he's also a founder and
Scientific Advisor for tell perion
Incorporated his focus is on machine
learning methods that incorporate
reproducibility interpretable
interpretability and uncertainty in
prediction accuracy and currently he
works on patient heterogeneity in
clinical trials Mike is one of the
creators of the big memory package one
of the very uh early Big Data Frameworks
that made our able to work with scales
of data outside of ram outside of memory
and a developer of the whole ecosystem
of packages around that a long time
friend of the and a developer of the art
ecosystem and particularly a long time
friend of the r Meetup so please welcome
Michael Kane
all right so
let's see I'm gonna
make it okay here we go
um
oh just a sec
huh
well
it's my slides are not showing up
all right
there's an index file there
oh
that's better okay
all right so um I uh so I have this so
I'm gonna talk about something
um it's a little it's a little bit
different it's uh about it's uh so about
this
these uh so I'm going to talk about the
intersection of drug development and
finance and a lot of the way I came to
this is that um I I work on clinical
trials I do analyzes for clinical trials
I have some back a little bit of a
background in finance I was an intern at
Barclays Capital uh in 2008 the year of
the mortgage meltdown
um that kind of cured me of wanting to
be like a Quant but I did I do really I
still like finance
and and I've done some Consulting for in
that area
um a part of this talk was basically
through interactions with uh in Industry
I ended up kind of hooking up with some
of the people at a at a large biotech uh
and who'd uh who do
um things like Acquisitions uh so one of
the really interesting things in finance
or sorry in um in in biotech or in drug
development is you have these companies
uh they end up they're either developing
drugs themselves or they're invested in
one or more drugs right and that could
be you know post-market which means that
they're already being delivered to
people or pre-revenue which means that
they're still in development and they'll
acknowledge that they have these
Investments that they're that they have
this portfolio but once you start asking
them about kind of really basic things
in finance like probability of success
for uh for uh for getting to Market and
then also valuation for the portfolio uh
things give the the conversations get
very very quickly
um
so part of this was me kind of going
through and seeing what what are people
in uh in Pharma doing right now when
they're thinking about drug development
and uh and a little bit for Acquisitions
and then how do we kind of quantify what
we know
um to be able to make better decisions
or at least assess risk right so this
talk will be basically in about three
different parts I've kind of got an
intro and background information on
clinical trials because I think those
are still those end up being kind of
mysterious to people I'm going to go
over then how I'm doing a lot of a lot
of analyzes in this area for mostly for
for Acquisitions but then also risk risk
assessment a lot of it boils down to
using a publicly available resource
called clinicaltrials.gov and we are I'm
going to show a package called sea
trials.gov that we use to access it to
access the entire database and then and
then be able to search for trials and
then I'm going to end with kind of some
of the applications that we've been
looking at looking at including these
competitive analyzes between mean off
between biotechs and pharmacists right
so just to demystify the the title so
what is pre-revenue pharmacopo finance
means so by pharmacofinance I'm just
talking about Finance related to drug
development and delivery a lot of times
when people talk about pharmacofinance
now a lot about a lot of it is about uh
is it is about how do you get drugs to
people that have already been approved
so I'm going to focus on pre-revenue so
this is where
the the drug or the compound has not
gotten through FDA approval
um
uh yeah uh and so so basically the uh
yeah so that and that happens FDA
approval happens after a view successful
review uh after phase three so just to
give you an idea of just as a reminder
of what the phases are and then also to
to just mention kind of what kind of
order of magnitude are we talking about
in terms of investment
um I'm gonna just I'm gonna focus on
oncology so that's cancer
um so you have a phase one study so uh
the goal of the phase one study is uh is
to figure out what dose should be used
so in oncology particularly in uh with
with chemotherapies uh basically so
chemotherapy is a is a toxic drug uh the
way that chemotherapy works is you're
literally like poisoning the person
hoping the cancer will die first right
so for phase for in phase one for
chemotherapy it's basically you want to
be able to give a person as much of a
chemo therapy as possible without
killing that person or causing you know
because or causing more damage than the
cancer would all right and usually when
you're thinking about investing for the
investing in those that's about a that's
about a that's probably less than a 10
million dollar investment most of the
time with trials like that uh especially
in oncology you're you're dealing with
patients that are extremely sick to
begin with and you're really just
looking for how much of this drug can I
give the person you're not as worried
about efficacy in phase one again
because a lot of these a lot of people
in this group in these trials are so
sick that they're probably not going to
see much of a much of a response all
right
phase two is where you start to actually
start you get towards efficacy
um so uh
so for you know for most studies in
oncology
um what you're doing in phase two is
you're looking at the recess score which
basically says are you is the drug able
to shrink the tumor so this is called a
surrogate endpoint because it's not
telling us whether or not it's affecting
survivability of the disease or or if
it's making it take longer for uh for
people to die it's mostly saying that we
think if we can shrink the drug or we
can shrink the tumor that it's going to
it's going to contribute to
survivability but we don't want to spend
the we don't want to invest in the
amount of time that it's going to take
to do that all right so when you get to
phase two you're usually talking about
order 50 million uh dollars
that's depending on uh depending on the
the type of cancer and uh and its
characteristics
so by phase three uh these are the
really big studies and these are the
ones that are going to get you to uh to
review to review so in this case we're
saying does it actually work right is it
going to increase survival
um or uh it's usually increased survival
and oncology
um and then is it going to work on a
large group all right so
these are kind of the orders of
magnitude that are uh that we're talking
about for uh for for investment for uh
for for drug development
all right so when I think of a clinical
trial
um or when I'm involved in a clinical
trial I'm usually thinking about a
couple of different things so first
indication
um essentially in which disease are we
evaluating the treatment the reason that
I'm I usually am interested in or the
reason I want to know this is because
you have very different uh profiles for
for trials depending on the disease that
you're looking at so for example
um I I've also worked in lupus which is
probably the most is the one of the most
complicated diseases that there is
especially in trying to figure out how
to treat it just because it presents in
so many different ways
the other problem that you have with
lupus a lot of times is you you have
people taking concomitant medications so
the big therapy for Lupus is uh is
steroid so it's prednisone which is
which works very effectively but you
can't but it's really detrimental to
Health in the longer term so for
something like lupus we're worried about
the effect of concomitant medication or
Placebo response where people think
they're getting better but it's really
that they're
um that they uh that they uh
their their symptoms are being
alleviated they they feel like they're
better but it could be either like I
said with lupus it's concomitant
medication or um you do see a lot of
times with uh either with migraine and
then also with psych meds people are
just going to start feeling better after
they after they start having a therapy
all right so another thing is uh so the
next thing is Phase so what phase are we
thinking about a trial for for design
and what is it that we're actually uh
trying to uh what's the goal for the
trial uh yeah
um
then there's also this idea of prognosis
so how do we expect people's disease to
progress this is really variable in
Trials especially in oncology because a
lot of times you have these trials that
are called all-comer trials meaning that
if you're you uh that you uh you're
allowed more they allow more people into
the trial but you run into a problem
with sometimes that you end up with
patients who may be like more what's
called refractory which means we don't
really think they're going to respond so
especially in oncology if you're older
or you've had a lot of different
therapies you're less likely to respond
than somebody who's younger who has
never had uh who's ever had been on any
kind of treatment right so this varies a
lot so this is
um this is patient heterogeneity
um and this is one of the things we end
up needing to manage
um after that then there's the trial
design how are we going to evaluate the
effect of the uh of
um of a therapy that's usually basically
creating a control arm and then a
treatment or multiple treatment arms and
thinking about how are we going to um
how are we going to see if there's a
difference and then finally there's the
analysis is how do we convince people
mostly people at the FDA that the
treatment is actually working all right
um so most statisticians when they talk
about trials they're talking about Trial
design but there's that is really the
tip of the iceberg in terms of what goes
into a trial all right so for a trial
you have operations and administration
so this is actually where most the money
goes
um like the statisticians aren't getting
that that 20 million dollars right
um
but so so here here's here's where
actually a lot of the money goes um so
there's this operations and
administration how do we get patients
how long is the trial going to take uh
because basically you're funding these
trials you're funding enrollment you're
funding the administration of of the um
of the therapy you're funding the data
collection uh and
um you're funding this over time right
so basically you have a number of
patients that you need to enroll to be
able to show a statistical difference uh
in uh in
um
in effect of the drug uh and and you're
basically and if your enrollment is slow
then your burning time as you're uh as
you're reaching that
um
enrollment is a big issue for certain
types of cancers especially rarer ones
so you do run into these cases where if
you're not enrolling at a at a high
enough rate you have to go back and say
how do we refund this
um and then or uh or or cut off the drug
um and then the last thing for
operations is a data capture and that's
actually still I think pretty primitive
that's usually done by people usually
nurses putting things into into Data
capture software all right so for
finance uh this is another thing that
statisticians in clinical trials don't
usually think too hard about so
um the things that the things that we're
going to look at is what's the trial
probability of success in other words
what
uh what's the probability that if I do
this and I get enrollment that it's
actually going to work right we can plan
for these things to work uh but we
actually want to be able to think about
what is that and we want to be able to
be able to capture that during the uh
during the trial
um what's the value the value this is
one of the hardest problems in clinical
trials like how do we actually value uh
one of these drugs especially before it
hits the market this usually depends on
what's the disease that the size of the
disease population if it's really rare
you do end up getting supplement
supplements usually from uh the the
government for uh for with orphan
disease designation so there are
incentives Beyond just the size of the
disease population and then a lot of it
boils down to though how much can you
charge can insurance companies charge
for it after that it's going to be who
will buy it that's both in terms of
insurance companies and then
um who's gonna and then how big is the
disease the size of the disease
population and then if you're if you're
running one of these things it's how do
you access Capital like I said um a lot
of times what happens is funders give
these really small biotechs so biotech's
money in the beginning for like a phase
two trial
um and then so so there there are these
issues of what happens if you run out of
money before you hit the end of the
trial
um and who are the people that you go to
with this uh right now this is a pretty
inefficient so there's not a lot of like
traditional Finance that's done if you
are a uh an investor right now it seems
to me like the best the the best thing
you can do is try to invest in as many
compounds as possible because if one of
them hits and one of these small
biotechs get through get through a phase
two trial then they usually get picked
up by a large Pharma for some multiple
of of the uh of the cost of the company
all right so
um so it reminds me of like like I hear
stories about people stories from
traders in the 80s right where like it
was like you know how do you how do you
decide on which stock or uh or financial
product you go to and like a lot of them
are like well we just kind of go on feel
you know we get to look at the data a
little bit we don't do like a tremendous
amount of analysis and because of that I
do feel like there's like I feel like
this is going to tighten up right like
these Finance people should be licking
their chops at the at the opportunities
for this
um but it does actually require uh a lot
more knowledge about the ex about the
clinical trial process all right
um
so like I said what are the goals for
this talk now that I'm 25 or so minutes
in uh is that right am I 25 minutes in
sure all right all right so I'm going to
just try to connect drug development
with Finance I'm going to show how we're
evaluating competing drug programs and
to show how our value evaluating trials
in terms of probability of success
um and there's definitely going to be
some R in there
um so just to go back that there is this
basically there's this market right now
where if you're a small biotech you're
essentially you have a a drug that
you're trying to get through
um
through regulation and you don't have to
get it all the way through phase three
what you really want to do is get it
through phase two
um and when you get through phase two
what happens is at that point you only
have phase three and
um and at that point the larger pharmas
are gonna are probably gonna buy you all
right and you also you want that because
you're basically a startup you're
basically funding the trial you don't
have the resources to actually uh uh for
for drug manufacturing or distribution
um right so here so these are these
really are like little startups the
problem that you have is is that when if
you don't hit uh FDA regular or if you
don't get FDA regulation your entire
evaluation is based on you getting
through uh through FDA so this is uh
this is an example of a company called
rovec that I think is no longer around
right now but earlier this year they had
they had a market cap of so this is uh
it's either June or July they had a
market cap of about 50 million dollars
right so they had investment they had
they were running the trial effectively
uh and then
again I think I guess this is
that's a why yeah so it's either June or
July 25th uh news comes out uh that that
they did not that that that they failed
phase two all right so because of that
overnight they lose uh 93 of their
entire value so this is part of the
reason a lot of Finance people don't
want to touch these small these small
biotechs right they're super volatile
um and you know you can get into
something and you can lose almost all
your value literally overnight right
um so this is this this is one of these
inefficiencies that we see in the small
in the small biotechsis
um basically the way they go to a funder
is they usually they don't get things in
tranches they just get a whole bunch of
money and uh the funder and and they say
they say to the funder all right I'll
see you at the end of this trial
um which which is which is is nonsense
right like the whole time during this
trial people are you're you're getting
response information for individuals
right you're figuring out is the drug
working
um you're getting this for more and more
people over time and part of the reason
you get this big snap is because
um that information is not being
integrated in in the market it's not
that the information isn't there this
company has it right but
not being
um it's not being conveyed to the people
who are investing in it right so if
you're in if you're
if you're investing these drugs which
you would like is
to see that this is going down right
because that lets you think about how do
I how do I de-risk this what do I want
to do with it and then possibly unwind
it before you hit this uh this surprise
this news the pro problem is the small
biotechs are not really incentivized to
do this right if they tell you our drug
stinks before the the trial is over
there you know then you know
they don't have to give that money back
basically
all right
um I have another example this was more
an administrative problem
um so from the perspective of the the
larger biotechs uh so this is this is a
calculation we did for a paper that
that's coming in like in another month
or two we're looking at the probability
of success for oncology indications of
getting through let's see uh probably of
success so this is Success successfully
getting through a review so this is
saying that if I'm about to start phase
one
this is the problem these are the
probabilities that I'm going to get all
the way through to review right so
they're super low you know this is the
orphans they're almost never going to
get through
um the ones that are doing better you
have this lead indicator that means that
the the drug was designed for uh for uh
for this disease and then so you get
through phase one you basically say all
right we can give this to people it
doesn't have terrible side effects
so then you get to phase two right and
then you actually start to get some
indication that it's doing well
um so this probability goes up this is
conditional again on starting phase two
that you're going to get through review
um but then when you get through
successful phase two all of a sudden
these jump up by a lot right so if
you're one of the big pharmas or big
biotechs
you don't you don't and you're thinking
about buying you don't want to have to
buy a phase one right because that drug
is probably not going to get through you
if you have to you might you might give
a little bit of investment in in at the
beginning of phase two but you also
don't want to so again so so what
happens is you have this Marketplace
that that happens after a successful
phase two at that point
um the the startup has essentially
de-risked uh the um or hasn't completely
but it's mostly de-risked or not even
mostly but it is de-risked the uh the
asset enough that it's something that
one that these larger guys are willing
to are going to be willing to just buy
right and especially now
um after kovid along with a couple of
these in oncology indications the the
big pharmas are flush right now with
money
um what's interesting also is that the
small the smaller biotechs right now a
lot of them are running out of money so
what you're probably we've already
started to see it but you're probably
gonna see these big guys just start
buying up these smaller guys just you
know just because there's not there's
not that much money they can they can
under bid on them and then they have
like this huge stable of other assets
that they can look at to get through
um to get through trials all right so
with r and how do I bring this back to
doing something useful and productive
with r so there's
there's this um there's this webpage
this is uh this is maintained by by the
government by the US government
um called clinicaltrials.gov any trial
that's running in the United States is
required by a law uh or yeah it's
required by law to register with
clinicaltrials.gov and also provide
information about
um the status of the trial and then also
a whole bunch of summary information
right so
um
so since it is regulated we can say that
the data are pretty good uh there's
about 420 000 trials in it uh and it
includes information like indication
that's the disease treatment enrollment
results Etc
um so what we ended up doing with this
because this is a really good resource
at least as much for for finance as it
is for people looking at compliance is
uh we wrote this package called C
trials.gov which is what I'm about to
start talking uh talking about it makes
heavy use of duct DB the entire database
is about uh I think it's about 13 gigs
so it's not big but it's big enough that
you probably don't want to do like a
read you don't want to do a read CSV for
it most of the time
um so you can throw it and so uh yeah
you can put it in a database we provide
search for trials mostly keyword
searches we also provide the entire
clinicaltrials.gov database or access to
that we're including derived features
like uh trial success probably or yeah
trial success whether or not the trial
was successful it's pretty tidy ngg plot
compatible
um and then it just and then it makes
these clinical trial summaries
accessible
so to show what this looks like if you
want to use it
if you if you're going to follow along
and do this at least for right now do
install the GitHub version because we've
made a whole bunch of changes that are
going to go to Chrome hopefully in the
next two or three weeks
um you just call it Library uh see
trials.gov the first thing you need to
do is get the current database which you
can do with there's a function called CT
ctgov get latest snapshot so the DB path
is this is going to be a snapshot of the
database as it is the ctgov derived is
going to be the version that that we use
all right
um
after that I can call the ctgov query
I'll show this a little bit more and
then I can do for a dimensions for
example and I can see that the last time
I did this there were 432 983 trials in
clinicaltrials.gov so this is all trials
not just the ones from industry uh there
are observational trials there were in a
whole bunch of other types right the
data set itself that we return from
uh from the
from the ctgov query function it's just
a data frame it's going to give you
kind of the basic information about the
trial that you need if you need to go
further again there's the original
snapshot and you can start you can start
querying that but this gives you just
kind of an idea of what it what it
actually looks like
all right so what are the kind of things
that we can we can do with this
um so I'm going to just start with
something that's pretty simple and just
say how many randomized trials this
Pfizer started this year
um so to do that I'll just load a d
player if you're just loading the the
database for the first time you do need
to say ctgov load.db file and this will
load the the the
ductdb database the derived database and
then you can just start querying so in
this case we want to say this the
sponsor keyword is going to be Pfizer
that's the company that's running the
trial the allocation is randomized like
I said before I'm going to start I'm
going to filter where the start date is
beginning of this year I'm going to
group by phase and then I'm just going
to do a summarize all right so you can
see there that's how many trials they're
running right now
um so what other kind of functionality
is supported
uh
here's a list
so there's a whole bunch of different
trial keyword querying that you can do
you can do intervention study or
intervention querying on intervention so
what was used or what's the treatment
that was that was under investigation
um searched by if the the trial was
successful this is one of these derived
data data that that we create
um
you have the dirt you have the original
tables if you want to look at that and
we do provide some kind of some
visualization and text similarity
all right so what other kinds of
analyzes can we do
um
so one of the things I want to look at
is uh so one thing you can you could say
is how often are amgen's trials
successful all right so the code for
this is again pretty straightforward
so I'm just going to look for
um the sponsor keyword and gen this is
going to be these are Interventional
trials and I'm just going to be a little
bit more specific probably than I need
to and say that I only want the industry
sponsored trials that means the industry
is is the lead sponsor all right then
what I'll do is I'll join that with with
this endpoint saying whether or not the
trial was successful
um I'm going to filter only trials that
are a little bit later because there's a
certain amount of time that you get to
um to update in clinicaltrials.gov so
I'm just gonna I'm gonna filter
everything before uh 20 2021 I'll Group
by phase and then I'll just look at how
many trials do I have and then uh and
then yeah how many trials do I have
which is going to be n how many times
did I get a yes or success and then I'll
just try to divide by the by n all right
I'm not going to worry about phase I'm
really going to worry about phase two
and three and four the other thing is
that we know this is a little bit biased
because they're the the reporting isn't
always great I think it's I think it is
pretty good though
um so basically since we've since we for
all the data that we have for Amgen
going back for to what we think is
reasonable these are these are the
success rates all right so what's really
interesting about Amgen is they are
awesome at getting phase three trial
files through through regulation all
right like better than most most other
companies in the industry
and this is the rate that's uh that uh
that that you're looking at right so
this is only about 32 percent
um again this is but if you were to go
to a lot of the other companies they
don't do quite as well I think Abby
comes the closest
all right
so
um another thing I can do is I can look
at timelines for uh for for uh for
oncology trials so what I'm going to do
is so so there's this there's a new
trial design it's called they're called
Innovative trials
um which is weird because they really
mean three different types of Trials
it's not that they're like
really Innovative it's basically it
means that it's a
their
um they're one of these types of Trials
called the umbrella basket Master
protocol and platform so what I can do
is if I want to look at the Innovative
trials or who's doing them and what are
their timelines then I'll grab these as
keywords I'll do another query on this
um
so my description keyword is going to
need to involve these Innovative trial
keywords and I'm just going to do a
brief title keyword that includes cancer
or carcinoma since I need to see one or
one or two uh I need to see either one
of those before I believe it's going to
be a cancer trial
um and then I'll just I'm only going to
look at since 2018. these are this is a
relatively new design there may be some
record of it going back further but we
don't expect to see too many before
2018. after that I'll just take the the
result of the query which is again just
a data frame I'm going to rename phase
just so it looks a little bit nicer and
then
and add a little bit of formatting
so the result is this you can see you
have a whole bunch of these so this is
just plotly
um you can see for example here's Pfizer
who else
sanofi has these three and these are
made such that if you Mouse over
and
well maybe yeah they usually
oh yeah all right I guess maybe it
doesn't work if I'm selecting it but if
I Mouse over the actual trial and click
on it it'll take me to the the the link
inclinical trials.gov right so if I want
to read more about it neither have it in
r or you can go in through and see and
look at the official reporting
right
um another yeah so
another thing we looked at was
um so uh is three drugs so this is a
teasalizumab nivolumab and pembrolizumab
so if you don't know these are probably
the most dominant immunotherapies the
immunotherapies showed up around 2011
and they they really changed cancer
survivability for a lot of different
indications this is showing them kind of
side by side about where they were so
the vertical line is where they are
presently and they're started at they're
all started at time zero so if you
wanted to think about what is a
competitive analysis look like for this
which company actually went out with
these immunotherapies uh this is this is
what it looked like you can see so
pembrolizumab for people don't that
don't know this is monetized at a rate
of over four billion dollars per quarter
right so this is a blockbuster these
other drugs they make they do well
they're probably probably hundreds of
millions of dollars per quarter but a
little bit less so you can see here this
is the uh
this is this is the number of concurrent
trials that are going on so this is
immuno an immunotherapy it doesn't just
work on one type of cancer
um and these these uh these concurrent
trials are basically uh these companies
getting uh starting drug trials for
different types of cancer
um you can see here pembrolizumab has
has topped out it looks like it's done
the best at 150 concurrent trials
um again this is the this is the biggest
therapy in this in this area nivolumab
is doing okay that's a little bit lower
uh a teasalizumab was uh I forget which
one was first might have been novel map
um a teasalizimab is really interesting
because it has this divot right
um it's not covid covet didn't really
stop these trials that much it was that
a teaselismab had I think it was in 2018
or 19 they had a failure in phase three
so this was after people figure out like
the immunotherapies are where we're
going to do a lot of development right
now they thought this is great you know
we can have these huge programs we can
keep getting these indications and make
more and more money a teslizumab goes
into it was bladder cancer and so they
were looking at the uh so it's pdl1
is the genetic Target that that
um that uh that that that these that
these guys are aiming for
um and they did an uncontrolled phase
two trial so they had only treatment no
control and it the the drug looked like
it was doing really well so they go into
phase three thinking like this is
immunotherapy we're going to get this
and what happened is that P it looks
like pdl1 is actually prognostic for
bladder cancer meaning if you have this
expression you tend to do better all
right so not only does it is uh is this
um uh this therapy predictive meaning if
I give it to somebody with PDL and
expression they're going to do they're
going to do well but it's also
prognostic and if somebody already has
pdl1x or has I guess it was pd1
expression it was going to be that they
were going to do better so they didn't
know that they were going up against a a
a better
um a better response rate until phase
three until they spent like their 150
million dollars or or whatever it is and
then uh and that caused this kind of not
cascading problem but a big problem uh
to their entire to their drug program so
because of that you get this divot they
were like what is good what's going on
with this how is this going to affect
all of our trials and
um what happens is these are horse races
right if you you need to get you want to
get your drug into every single
different type of cancer that you can
and you want to be the first one because
that's where you're going to make most
of your money and it's going to be
harder for other people to get in so
because they failed there that causes
this problem they lose time they're not
able to get uh into as many indications
as something like pembralism which has
just been which has been going like
gangbusters right
um
so I am about out of time right five or
so minutes
yeah all right I could I can talk for
10.
all right is it okay if I talk for ten
all right okay so I wanted to show a
couple of the other types of analyzes
that we that we end up doing
um and I want to actually do a little
better job of showing you or motivating
some of the problems that you have you
can do with with c-trial scuff so one of
the things that we did was we started
looking at um again going back to this
idea of portfolio so I can use
clinicaltrials.gov to get all of the
um all of the all of the the trials for
a given company in this case it's Amgen
then what I can do is I can say all
right I'll do other queries where I'll
look for all the drugs in phase one
where
um the title or the description is
similar right so basically I'm looking
for same phase
um same disease all right so there's
kind of this like NLP problem there so
if I do that
and I say well how many historical
trials do I have like that and then I go
through and say how many of those were
successes what happens is I can kind of
come up with this Baseline probability
of uh um of it being a success right so
I could say
all right I know this is still in in
trial I don't know what's going to
happen but what happened what's happened
historically in that phase for that
disease all right so once you do that
again a little bit of NLP because
there's not because you have to do a
little bit of registration with the um
with the disease like sometimes they're
really specific sometimes they're
targeting biomarkers
um but it's not it's not it's not too
bad so then you can come up with this
this like I said Baseline probability of
success all right so for example this
one uh this Amgen is in a phase three uh
so this is atopic dermatitis
um
so that's a that's like a rash on your
skin uh so there are about 98 historical
trials in phase three looking at atopic
dermatitis the success rate has
historically been about 40 percent all
right so this gives you if you're if
you're a kpi person you know basically I
have the portfolio I have a baseline set
of probabilities and I can say am I
beating uh my these Baseline
probabilities and if I if I am then I
could say all right my portfolio is
doing well or we're doing we're doing a
good job with drug development
um the administration and then also the
operations all right
so I can take that
and I can say all right well that's just
for Amgen so let's let's not worry about
just Amgen let's let's grab all of the
bigger Pharma and biotechs right so what
I'll do then is I'll get the I'll um for
phase two I'll say what's the rate of
that
um
so sorry basically
I'll I'll take these guys
these portfolios then I'll average over
uh over the success rate
for phase two
and I'm going to get this now there are
better ways you can do this this is
really just kind of summery
um and we've gotten a bit more
sophisticated about about that but this
is kind of this this expect an
expectation what's your uh what's your
rate of success for in phase two
um
based on that we know we also know how
many uh how many uh of these drugs they
have in trial right now right so we're
saying we can say that for this current
cohort for ADV for example that we think
that uh about three of their 21 drugs
are going to go are going to go forward
all right
um now phase two again this is this is
higher risk
these guys have money where they if they
want to if they want to pay for pay for
pay to mitigate risk they can do that
and that really mostly happens in phase
three and here's where you where you do
see that historically like you have
these rates for so phase three rate you
have 35 36 for AstraZeneca and then 35
for ABV basically uh these these guys
are have a lot of success in phase three
but they also have the uh more drugs uh
yeah more drugs that appear in uh appear
historically in clinicaltrials.gov so if
you think about what this means it means
that they're not they're not trying to
hit home runs a lot of times right like
if you are able to develop a drug for a
new disease or new disease area
um that's much that's high risk uh
you're probably going to make more but
at the same time you're going to pay for
that risk these guys are saying we don't
necessarily need to do that we want a
big part of our portfolio to be such
that we're going to go through phase
three we know what the indication looks
like it may be kind of a marginal
increase in uh in in in hell in or yeah
maybe marginally better for patient care
but at the same time like we don't care
we want to get these we want to get
drugs to Market not take not swing for
the fences uh and and lose money some of
these other companies are like order
orders of magnitude bigger like Pfizer
is enormous
um so so is Roche so they don't actually
mind uh they're doing pretty well but
they also don't mind uh taking on a bit
more risk all right
phase four I'm a little bit less
interested in so the other thing is and
I'll go back to phase three for these
guys is that if you're one of these
companies
um
and you start getting hits you start
getting into good you get getting good
reviews you don't necessarily release
the drug immediately the reason is you
don't want to show you don't want to
make it look like you're having trouble
innovating or not getting things to to
Market so you can go through like a
successful review and then hold off and
say you know we've got it looks like
we've got three or four drugs that we're
going to release next year why don't we
hold off a little bit so that the
following year we can say we've got at
least this one coming out
um
so these are basically the in
expectation the number of drugs that
these companies could put out at the
time um when the trial comes to an end
which is more data that's that's
available in clinicaltrials.gov so this
is kind of the number of drugs that uh
that that we think that that they can
get out
um again this is conditioned on there
being historical data there if it's not
historical then then we've been saying
that this is um uh the development of a
new indication uh and that's kind of a
separate analysis
um but you get the idea then this is
kind of this is kind of this is how many
drugs these companies will probably
release in the next couple of years
all right
um
I have a little bit on new indications
I'm not going to get into that
um
yeah so the the package itself is on uh
like I said it's on cran that's a older
version if you are interested in it do
go to
um use the devtools version Let me just
go back to that so people can take a
quick look
if you have feedback or anything like
that uh you're please do let us know
um and thanks
foreign
well I have one question that
technically was in the chat but it's my
question so I'm going to start with it
sure um so uh going back to that early
volatility that the investors see and
the sudden change yeah uh is that so you
said they have that data but the
investors don't see it is that because
those are sort of closed trials and
they're not allowed to release it as
they go or is it just that there's
inefficiency here and the investors
aren't asking for the right data or not
getting it there's real inefficiency
here uh in fate and so in phase two you
are allowed to look at the data and
phase three is a little bit different
where you only get
um one or two looks at the data and you
have to power for that but in phase two
you're mostly you're you're getting data
you know um when um
uh you know how people are doing there
are administrative delays uh like uh
doing things like verifying
um that a response actually is a
response but at the same time you don't
actually need that to uh to be able to
come up with a better model for a
probability of success this time
technically like everybody
sorry typically everybody doesn't have
access to data I mean you have you have
um simple or more complex and something
like this probably simple you know um uh
futility and you know or
you know early stopping for Success you
know rules that sort of thing but you
you have to give them be you know
whatever who couldn't see these things
in real time not
you know yeah so at least at least
that's supposed to be the way that way
yeah so so the the data comes in as case
report forms that form is different than
what's submitted to the FDA which are
called sdtms or atom format and atom
formatted data but you have a lot you do
have a lot of data that's that that's
gonna so all of the data that's used for
the analysis is derived from those
um along with a little bit extra where
you have something like
um
uh uh you do have a couple cases where
um where you do um not mediation it's
the um uh we're we're basically
um where you need you need more than one
expert to say yes this was in fact a
response but
need that information and those case
report forms are usually held by like a
um a data capture company and these like
these companies have direct access to
all of that data over the entire course
of phase two right like they you could
use this you could allow funders to have
a much better idea of what they're doing
or forget the uh uh not worrying about
the the really small biotechs for these
mid or large size biotechs you know they
could be doing uh that they could be
doing a lot more to do um to do real
time or it's not real time even pricing
at the at the monthly level to get a
better idea of of what their portfolio
is doing
although that that my if if things are
starting to look bad but not you haven't
reached your a futilities that you're
going to have a lot more problems with
enrollment say that's that's true um you
do also yeah you do get other weird
problems with enrollment you know like
where a new drug
um people will want to get on it from um
from rumor right some may be like
somebody has a good response it's like
oh you gotta get you got to get on this
drug so that that is true but that's
kind of that is a that's a problem you
kind of have in general
um with with enrollment
um no it's certainly true that it in the
last 10 years when with uh so many so
much being
basically given this sort of discrete
social media not the usual sort of thing
people talk who are in a clinical trial
we'll talk about their experience
um they might not even know what group
they're in but you know it's like that
depending on trial but um
it can
cause a great deal stir in them people
who are actually looking for this you
know relatively rare
disease or something you know for
Salvage cases in this disease or
something like that yeah that's a good
point because in that case then you can
almost think of enrollment as being it's
not always but it's but is related to
um people's perception of how well the
the the the the the the
therapy but also yeah so many people who
would qualify for trials don't enroll so
you know that is that is more of an
Institutional failure yes yeah I'm sorry
to be talking so much
so before uh I get to next questions I
just want to let people know that our uh
ticket winners for the uh are in
government uh conference on December 1st
and 2nd are Michael Zions uh and Mark oh
my gosh Mark Bauer is here in the room
Michael Zions in the in the in the chat
so uh uh talk to talk to Nicole Michael
uh DM Nicole uh in the the slack for
your tickets
um I have a
um an r package Development question
yeah for this so you provide these 400
000 records some auto records as a duck
DB database yeah so do you
uh like do the
um like data processing for that and
then have that like object to be
downloaded yeah so but what this will do
is this is going to use Curl to go to
um it's aacti there's a web page
basically that has these latest
snapshots it will download it uh as part
of that thing you download you can get
it's the pipe delimited files for all of
the tables in the database there are
about 50 of them
um so it will it'll go out it'll grab
those
um all right process the pipe to limited
files and write them to
ctgov duckdb and then we use that to to
create this set of derived features that
that the package uses pretty heavily ah
so that processing happens for the
user's machine it's not like it's not
like you are using Ci or something to
process these snapshots and you're not
in the business of like providing things
to download you're providing the like
essentially the ETL pipeline in the r
package right for people to grab from
this source and sort of do the import
and the cleaning and come out the other
side with the nice sort of structure
that you've developed exactly yeah sure
yeah it's lar yes if you look at the
documentation for the web page they show
how to do it in postgres
which is a total pain right like people
like we don't it's not that big it's
only about 12 gigs
um so postgres seems like a that's a
really big hammer to handle a data set
that big duckdb I feel like at around 12
gigs you're kind of you're getting into
the sweet spot for for duckdb
um or you know if you want to do your
sqlite that's fine I just uh I yeah yeah
I've been using duckdb I I like it so
that was kind of what we went with
gotcha
do we have other questions
no
okay
well thank you very much Mike all right
thanks thank everyone for coming thanks
everybody in the chat
uh yeah message Nicole uh next month's
Meetup uh we should have an announcement
up in the the next week uh we're gonna
have it once again it'll be uh hybrids
it'll be online and in person for those
who are in New York uh yeah and have a
good night thank you